Hi, I'm Jarek Wilkiewicz,
and I'm a developer advocate.
I was born in Poland.
And like many other
engineers, I grew up
reading science fiction.
In fact, this is
my favorite author.
My childhood home
was actually very
close to his house in Krakow.
And little did I know
that his work would
have major influence on my life.
Did you red science fiction too?
Do you remember the moment
when the protagonist,
while busy saving the
world, asks her computer
for something?
Computer, make it so.
And the machine just
does it, and it nails it.
Now, why can't the real
world be more like this?
For example, when a
user says, OK, Google,
and asks for something,
the applicational service
most suitable to
fulfill the request
should be involved and get
the job done just like that.
Today I want to talk to
you about technology-based
on Schema.org
Actions, which I think
is a small step
in that direction.
With Actions, we
have an opportunity
to delight your users and bring
more engagement to your app.
However, we can't do it alone.
We need your help.
At Google, we have been working
on organizing the world's
information to
make it universally
accessible and useful.
To help with that we've
built the Knowledge Graph.
The Knowledge Graph
contains information
about entities and
their relationships.
One of the interesting
applications of the Knowledge
Graph is resolving
ambiguities when
processing language queries.
For example, the
artist Dual Core
is a band, which is different
than the concept of dual core.
As far as the strings are
concerned, these two are equal.
But to a user who is asking
their phone to play Dual Core,
the difference is quite clear.
Dual Core the band is assigned
a machine ID in the graph.
We like to refer to these types
of object-based identifiers
as things, not strings.
Having a graph entity
with a machine ID, or MID,
makes a big difference.
The Knowledge Graph can also
help satisfy user requests
with your application.
I thought a good way to show you
how this works is to actually
build a small Knowledge
Graph together with you.
But first, let me introduce
you to my buddy Shawn.
This is Shawn.
We both like music.
Shawn likes to DJ and spin
dance LPs in his free time.
One day, we would love
to open a record store.
We would curate an
awesome selection of LPs.
And on weekends, we would
invite our favorite artists
to give concerts at our store.
Now, wouldn't that be great?
Our music selection
would of course
be available for
purchases online.
We would offer web and mobile
streaming access as well.
Since today most
music recommendations
are provided by
computers, we would
want to make it
easy for computers
to discover and understand
what we have to offer.
For example, when
they user says,
OK, Google, play
Dual Core, we would
like our out to be ready
to fulfill users request.
All right.
So we have this music store.
We are selling LPs,
offering streaming access,
and hosting events on weekends.
How do we express
this information
in the machine readable way?
And how would it be used?
Let's look at a simple
architecture diagram.
The flow of information
is illustrated
by the direction of the arrows.
As you can see, the
crawler fetches data
from our music website and
saves it in the Knowledge Graph.
The graph is then consulted
when the user issues
a voice command or a web search.
Sean and I publish
this information
about our music artists and
albums on our store website.
Now, how do we do that?
Rather than inventing a
new publishing format,
we will apply the
lined data principles.
The term "linked data" refers
to a set of best practices
for publishing and connecting
structured data on the web.
We'll use Schema.org vocabulary
and JSON-LD serialization
to describe the entities
in our music store.
If you haven't heard about
JSON-LD or Schema.org,
don't worry.
Click the links on the
screen or follow along.
It's pretty straight forward.
For example, here's what an
artist looks like in JSON-LD.
The JSON-LD markup is
embedded in an artist web
page on our site.
Now, take a look at
the sameAs property.
This property will
make it easier
to reconcile a match-- the
JSON-LD document describing
an artist with a corresponding
entity in our Knowledge Graph.
In the spirit of linked
data, the sameAs property
links the artist with
information on another site.
This stuff is pretty
important, but we'll
show you more about how
that's used in the next video.
As I mentioned earlier,
we built a mobile app
so our customers can
enjoy music on the go.
How do we express the fact
that our music artist we carry
can be listened
to using our app?
Remember, I want our
mobile app to be triggered
by the OK Google voice command.
Fortunately, we can also
use Schema.org and JSON-LD
for that.
A recent addition to the
Schema.org vocabulary
makes it possible
through something
called potential Actions.
Here's an example.
Note that in our
markup, we are making
an association between an artist
and the mobile application
we have built.
Let's recap.
Shawn and I described our store
using JSON-LD and Schema.org,
so now this information
is machine readable.
We have also associated
our music app with artists
that it can handle.
Does this mean that
our music app will now
be triggered when
the user asks Google
to listen to the music
we have marked up?
Not quite.
First we need to test.
There are several things
that can go wrong.
We want to verify.
The crawler has to
be able to parse
the JSON-LD markup
we have published.
Artists described in
our JSON-LD documents
have to successfully
reconcile or match
with entities in
our Knowledge Graph.
Our mobile app has to
handle specific intents
so that the music starts playing
when the app is triggered.
Quite a few things
to test, isn't it?
Don't worry.
To help you with
testing all this,
we have provided sample
open source implementations
of the components you see
highlighted in this diagram--
the website, the mobile
app, the crawler,
and the small
Knowledge Graph running
in the graph database
called Cayley.
We have also built a
mobile and web simulator
to help you trigger the
Schema.org actions defined
in the JSON-LD documents
for the music store.
All right.
What do we do next?
Now that our JSON-LD markup
is on our music store site,
we can run the crawler to make
sure our markup is correct.
The crawler parses
the JSON-LD markup
and transforms it into a
graph database called Triples.
It looks like this.
If this sounds
intriguing to you--
it sure is for me--
see the second video
where the my colleague
Barak will show you
how the output of the
crawler can be loaded
into an open source
database called Cayley.
Barak will also show you how
you can join the music store
data with Freebase, a free
structured data repository
with millions of people,
places, and things.
If you would rather skip
ahead and learn more about how
the entities published on
our music store website work
in conjunction with
Schema.org actions,
see the third video
in this series.
Better yet, clone the
repository that we have shared
and play around with
the code before you
proceed to the next video.
Thank you, and have a great day.